what up though this is big snoop dogg  and i'm hosting snoop and martha's very  tasty halloween special but right now  i'm gonna take some questions from the  people  i get scared  michael myers  and which one will have black people  that live  get out  mother  ice cream  to catch a touchdown pass from tom brady  on deion sanders  dailan dailan dailan dailon dailan  yes willie nelson 420 amsterdam he  smoked me under the table i had to take  a commercial break  favorite snooper ball memory my little  league team had a football game on  saturday and the pittsburgh steelers  came to see my team and then the next  day the pick first tellers won the super  bowl and i party one what a deal  thank you buzzfeed  make sure you go check out snoop and  martha's very tasty halloween playing on  peacock and tell them snoop dogg sent  you  [Music]  you